in his major league debut ryan mount
castle leads the orioles
no wait a minute here they come and that
lefty is john means yeah this is an
all-star pitcher last year for baltimore
off to a really slow start he strikes
out devers here and boy
does john means look good to start 95
at the belts well i'll tell you he keeps
pitching like this he will be the story
tonight make no mistake about that
that's a fastball just right up in the
zone tonight's opener
colt brewer he's done everything for the
red sox this year
the offering is home he swings and laces
one into left field they said
nunez up to second base and that was
another mistake pitch from brewer
a couple men on base with two outs and
ruiz stepping up
and a routine ground ball to peraza he
gets out of it two orioles stranded
xander he hits last night
there's a drive out to left field on the
move mount castle turning around
that ball is into the bullpen the pick
to click
has hit a home run
xander bogarts with number six one
nothing boston takes it out of the
ballpark for the second straight night
this one
this one much hotter than last night and
the fact is
you know he's always hit means well
now batting for the orioles and making
his major league debut
left fielder number six ryan
mount castle and it's low and away
ryan mount castle first big league plate
appearance
everybody's talking about he needs to
improve his plate discipline
and he walks to lead off the second he
is
over for one with a ground out to third
swinging a high drive in the center
field this ball is crushed mullen's back
at the
wall he leaps it is gone
jd martinez hammers a
fastball into deep center field and
jd has his third home run the red sox
lead it
three to nothing he did not miss that
one
and that one takes a load off martinez
and back to him nice play by brewer to
grab that
on o2 a sharp ground ball through the
shift
base hit santander and his major league
leading hit streak is up to 16 games
runner not going curveball called strike
three on the inside corner he got him
that was a beauty and colton brewer has
found the hook see colton brewer moves
on for the fourth inning the bullpen is
still quiet here is a cutter swung on
and lying down the right field line long
run for
pillar over toward the line he dives in
foul territory
and he makes the play wow superman dive
onto the warning track in foul ground
and kevin pilar
spectacular for the first out in the
fourth here's the catch here
on statcast so you're going to see pilar
take off running from his right field
position
29.7 feet per second
98 feet there's nothing average about
that play i can tell you
by him for strike three three cutters
and sets him down
building something here in the fifth
rafael devers to bat with two on
fly ball center field that one way back
there and
kiss that one goodbye deep into the
bleachers
for his fourth home run of the season
and the red sox are on top
six to nothing oh get the tape this
change
up went about 450 feet i mean
whoa that's a change up down that he
puts an
absolute job
that's a base hit down the right field
line santan there has to give chase
vasquez all the way to third and diving
into second base
for dugo as he picks up an extra base
well you can't sleep on him so now
here's chavis who's lined out in ground
dutch pitch to chavis is a ground ball
up the middle and into center field to
base hit vasquez scores behind him for
dugo two runs single for chavis
and it's eight nothing red sides
there you go into left field pat
valencia he homered in the seventh
inning last night
and he does it again slider just sitting
right in the middle plate and it's
screaming the whole way just hit me and
you talk about hitting me
pat the leica does one away and nobody
on for cedric mullins
2-1 to mullins he swings and skies the
ball out towards left field verdugo
backs up at the track
again and it's back to back orioles
home runs cedric mullins touch them all
orioles lighting up osich they cut in
eight to two
and he takes it high ball four
[Applause]
so the first hit will wait but ryan matt
castle
is on base twice with a couple of walks
in his big league debut so two on two
out for cisco
driven to left field by cisco berdugo
racing back to the wall
it's out of here chance cisco
with an opposite field lefty lefty three
run blast and the orioles
are alive in the eighth inning and the
orioles have a shot here in the bottom
of the night
lays down a bunt devers will glove it
and he has no
play and mullins is aboard to lead off
the night
so the orioles last hope rests in the
two-tone bat of renato nunez
and the 0-1 pitch to nunez
and a ground ball xander bogart digs it
and the red sox have won again 8-5
the final score here tonight in
baltimore the sox win their third
consecutive game
and the second in a row here against the
orioles